this is a program in quantum information
science which is one of the most
exciting growth areas of science ranging
all the way from physics and engineering
to mathematics and computer science and
we've learned already in quantum
information is that our ideas about what
information is and how one might process
it for communications or for computation
we're in fact too naive the physical
theory of quantum mechanics teaches us
that information has some aspects that
until the past 15 or 20 years no one
really appreciated ever since then we've
been trying to figure out how can we
bring these new insights to bear to
develop completely new paradigms in
computation as well as in communications
and figure out what problems those are
going to let us solve more efficiently
than we were able to with any
conceivable classical computer quantum
information science is first and
foremost a proposes a new technology
quantum computers and the general public
has heard about those that's pretty
exciting but what is less known by
everyone is that quantum information
science also proposes a new way to
pursue knowledge in other areas of
science maybe studying black holes will
inform us on how to build a quantum
computer and new methods to build
quantum computers can tell us give us
insights into condensed matter physics
so we've we've built this extremely
broad group of researcher that cover
many aspects of quantum information
science but what a program like ours
needs to do is not just build a computer
and solve the problem that FedEx has
already ordered but rather try to
demonstrate what determines which are
the right problems to use a quantum
computer for there are no quantum
information science department in any
university it's a new field it is by
definition by definition
interdisciplinary so it needs a place
like CFR where people that would not
meet otherwise can teach each other and
can learn from each other what's special
about C far is that it affords an
opportunity to bring together a truly
multidisciplinary group
people who understand different aspects
of a problem and their everyday lives
don't necessarily have the opportunity
to interface with the people from all
the different aspects of that problem
[Music]